my name is Paul Marshall and I'm a
police officer here at San Jose State
when we ride the zeros we ride them it's
just an ordinary assignment it's just
the vehicle that we take out on patrol
that day
they're a great tool to have here on the
university you can go in through these
little areas that any patrol car can't
there's a lot of obstacles throughout
the campus with the bikes we can pretty
much go anywhere whether it be a medical
emergency or a police emergency of some
sort we can be there much quicker than
to have to park the car or get out and
get there oftentimes were the first ones
on scene
with zeros being so quiet we're able to
roll right up on something or somebody
and they had no idea we were coming we
can go down a sidewalk as opposed to
putting on all our emergency lights and
going the wrong way on a one-way street
in a car which creates quite a hazard we
take them downtown San Jose on city
streets we make car stops ped stops
bicycle stops
we're just more at one with everything
that goes on here then being closed off
in our patrol cars